[Musik]
anfang oktober und noch sommerliche
temperaturen in der stadt fürstenfeld
im fokus stehen diese woche nicht die
tat sondern europas größte ik t
sicherheitskonferenz
organisiert vom amt des österreichischen
bundesheeres dreht sich hier alles um
cyber-sicherheit also wie es wichtiger
aspekt der konferenz man kann lernen von
dem modernen gute erfahrungen der
sicherheitsmaßnahmen haben
man kann auch lage bilder austauschen
was passiert in anderen ländern eher
andere institutionen mit diesem baby
wissen bewaffnet kann man die eigene
sicherheit optimieren
rund 2000 teilnehmer erwarten über 60
vorträge von cyber security experten
hier geht es um themen wie industrie 4.0
kritische infrastrukturen bis hin zum
mensch als week as point
ein besonders aktuelles
bedrohungsszenario ist zum beispiel wird
black out loud experte habe sei doch nur
eine frage der zeit also die brauer
spricht schon länger von es ist nicht
die frage ob sondern wann
weil ich beschäftige mich seit dem jahr
2011 mit diesem thema und wie die
entwicklung mehr zu einer letzten acht
jahren gelaufen sind und das was in den
nächsten fünf jahren auf europäischer
ebene geplant ist die ich fix davon aus
dass wir in dieser zeit dieses eigenes
erleben werden das thema aus
untersuchungen dass bis zu hört dass
rund ein drittel der bevölkerung
spätestens am vierten tag und zwei
drittel spätestens am siebten
ausreichend selbst versorgen können und
wir müssen aber davon ausgehen dass vor
einer woche keine versorgung mehr
angreift und geschweige denn zu
normalität erreicht werden kann und
daher also so wichtig dass jeder
persönlich diese vorsorgemaßnahme
unterricht und zu - zwei wochen selbst
über die runden kommen zu wollen
neben spannenden vorträgen bieten über
50 aussteller namhafter wie kt
unternehmen einen einblick zu den
aktuellsten technologien
[Musik]
während der konferenz findet auch das
finale der cyber security challenge
statt
dabei messen sich die 20 besten schüler
und studenten
ziel ist es junge talente frühzeitig zu
erkennen und zu fördern
denn nicht nur das bundesheer ist in
zeiten wie diesen besonders auf
nachwuchstalente angewiesen doch nicht
jede challenge findet im virtuellen raum
statt
bei outdoor übungen lernen sich die
jungen teilnehmer besser kennen
so sollen auch einzelkämpfer erfahrungen
in der gruppe machen zusammen
gemeinsames ziel und erleben sich dabei
erfolgreich zu sein indem sie gemeinsam
einlassen auf aufgabenstellung fragen
stellung und einander besser kennen
werden
es ist sinnlos mégane dass man dann die
stärkung von jedem einzelnen dann können
haben und das team danach entsprechend
genutzt für bleibende eindrücke sorgte
vor allem die vorbereitung für die
präsentation die ideen und bei
präsentationen
die skate dann und auf jeden fall
wiederkommen die farbe auf die
präsentation oder körperpackung schon
und performance gestern gelernt haben
die jungen talente während der zeit in
fürstenfeld vor allem eines definitiv
das thema sehr wichtig ist die
verschiedenen komponenten dass man
zusammenarbeiten dass man einander zu
verstehen
und das nur weil sich jetzt das
funktionieren könnte wissen dass das
muss wie vor besorgnis vorbereitung ist
alles was man von pretzsch fußgängern
und es ist auch noch mal lernt er wie
wichtig dass es ist dass man kooperiert
und dass man sie das als voraussetzung
dass das aber schien hat nachher mit
einem team wie aus einer kleinen idee
hat riesige riesiges werk entsteht und
große kreativität einfließen und im
endeffekt daraus auskommen
[Musik]